اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح اهلا بكم عشرات
الشهداء اثر استئناف اسرائيل قصفها الجوي
والمدفعي على انحاء مختلفه من القطع وذلك
بعد انتهاء الهدنه المؤقته صباح اليوم حيث
شهدت الساعات الاخيره انتهاء عمليه تبادل
الاسرى بافراج اسرائيل عن 30 فلسطينيا
واطلاق المقاومه صراحه ثمانيه
اسرائيليين
وزاره الصحه في غزه تؤكد الحاجه الى ضمان
تدفق الامدادات الطبيه والوقود لكل
المستشفيات ومكتب الاعلام الحكومي يعلن
ارتفاع حصيله الشهداء الى اكثر من 15000
والاصابات الى ما يزيد عن
36000 وحمل المجتمع الدولي مسؤوليه
استمرار الحرب وقتل المدنيين والاطفال
كتائب القسام تستهدف دبابات اسرائيليه
شمال مدينه غزه وتقصف تجمعات لجنود
اسرائيليين وجيش الاحتلال يتحدث عن اطلاق
عشرات الصواريخ من القطاع ويؤكد جرح احد
سكان سديروت ومصادر اسرائيليه تعلن اصابه
عدد من الجنود في معارك على اكثر من
محور قطر تؤكد ان المفاوضات لتمديد الهدنه
مستمره وانها ستفعل كل ما يلزم للتهدئه
وتدعو المجتمع الدولي الى تحرك سريعا لوقف
القتال في حين قالت حركه حماس ان الاحتلال
رفض التعاطي مع ثلاثه مقترحات للتبادل
بينما نفى مسؤول اسرائيلي اجراء اي
مفاوضات لتحرير مخطوفين الى
اللقاء